by now all of us know how to find the
cube of a number so 3 when cubed gives
us 27
it means 3 x 3 x 3 equals 27 so what is
a cube root well the cube root of 27 is
3 that's all this is the most important
concept of cube roots the rest of the
video will just focus on how cube roots
are denoted and its application so
remember 3 cubed is 27 and cube root of
27 is 3 well this is how the symbol of a
cube root looks like a root sign with a
3 here so we can say that the cube root
of 27 is 3 and as we saw in the square
root video this root sign is called a
radical and the number inside it is
called the radicand or the base here's a
better way to understand the concept of
cubes 4 cubed equals 4 times 4 times 4
which equals 64 we all know this this 3
when taken to the other side becomes
cube root hence we can say that the cube
root of 64 equals 4 now we're on our way
to understand a very interesting concept
we will try to understand this concept
with just one example we know that cube
root of 64 is 4 this example looks very
simple but modifying it slightly can
make it interesting let's play with
these numbers we can write 64 as 2
raised to 6
hence cube root of 64 can be written as
cube root of 2 raised to 6 we can also
write 64 as 4 cubed
hence we write this as cube root of 4
cubed now let's try writing 4 in an
exponential form 4 can be written as 2
squared
hence this would equal 2 squared and of
course it can
also be written as 4 raised to 1 what do
we observe yes when we take a cube root
of a number in exponential form the base
remains the same and the exponent is
divided by 3 6 became 2 & 3 became 1
remember when we take a cube root of a
number in exponential form we should
keep the base same and divide the
exponent by 3 let's quickly look at a
couple of examples say we want to find
the cube root of 4 raised to 9 the base
actually equals 262,000 144 imagine
finding the cube root of this big number
but using our technique all we need to
do is keep the base same and divide the
exponent by 3 here the base is 4 hence
we write a 4 here and divide 9 by 3
hence we get the cube root of 4 raised
to 9 as 4 raised to 3 now let's try
finding the cube root of 7 raised to 6
we can write it as 7 raised to 6 by 3
which equals 7 raised to 2 so remember
keep the base same and divide the
exponent by 3 in the coming videos we
will see how we can calculate the cube
root of large numbers which are not in
exponential form